hello YouTube on a rabbi part of the
religious group you enter World Economic
Forum and we have come here and I have a
short parable it's like two people in a
boat in the midst of the ocean one of
the man is drilling a hole in the boat
and the other one says you're killing
yourself you're killing me too why are
you doing it and the answer of the ax
man is well I'm only drilling a hole in
my part of the boat we are all in the
boat so we have come to repentance
because they bankers and all of us have
made grave mistakes as a rabbi I also
want to say that I feel the pain of
every Palestinian child was wounded and
killed in Gaza I feel the pain of every
Israeli child but I think sharing a pain
is the one way in which we can really
built the peace and therefore if
religious leaders here in Devil's we
have made his appeal let's try to look
in each other's eyes we need each other
and you know no I was a child in 1943 a
baby and I was saved by a Catholic woman
a German woman and she opened the door
for me let's open the doors to all the
babies of the world and therefore if I
have one request do all the business
before the politicians the religious
people to you let's together make sure
that the Millennium Development Goals
will be realized which means that in
2050 every child in the world will have
basic education that every child will
have fresh water and when we do that
then we are trustworthy and then we have
repented and will be peace